we begin with developing news and metro
police are investigating a deadly
officer-involved shooting overnight
that stemmed from a home burglary it
happened around 2 a.m in the spanish
hills neighborhood
that's near tropicana and durango bianca
holman's been there live
since early this morning she joins us
now bianca we know it's a gated
community do they know how that suspect
got inside
the spanish hills neighborhood is a
gated community with a guard
now this morning during the metro
briefing that we attended
they told us they did not want to
speculate about how the intruder got
inside
now a 911 call and a home security
system alerted police
to the robbery we're told there were two
people in the home when a man broke in
metro police told us what happened once
they arrived
as officers arrived on scene and
approached the house they could see the
suspect
inside the house officers made entry
into the house and immediately saw the
suspect
armed with a hammer attempting to attack
the homeowner
officers fired their weapons and the
suspect was struck
a scary situation for those two people
who were inside
police called the ambulance and when
they got to the house they pronounced
the suspect dead
this is the 18th involved officer
shooting from metro
this year now we're also told that no
officers were injured during this
incident
and over the next 72 hours the sheriff
will provide an update and also that
body camera footage from the officers
that were at this incident reporting
from durango and tropicana bianca homan
8 news now